Rett Brown the head coach the red-hot
Sixers back here on the show how are you
coach rich I'm doing great
if I told you that night when you joined
us
prior to drafting Ben Simmons that this
is the situation you would be in right
around tax day in April of 2018 what
would you told me I said I would want to
speak to you a lot more frequently than
we had been talking not that I bet
what's the process now coach in regards
to the generals what are the process the
Sixers right now as you get out of this
season second season just trying to to
continue to play the style of play you
know Joelle went out and we sort of sped
up you know we look at the 3-point a lot
and trying to understand how that's
going to play out in the in the playoffs
you know format in the spirit of the
playoffs and then trying to judge when
we're going to be able to reintroduce
Joelle back into to to our team probably
those few things you know as we go into
the Miami series and most on my mind so
do you think that embiid being worked
back in can happen during the Miami
series I think he can I don't know when
um none of us really do know it's it's
one of those things he does his cardio
work you know we put him through sort of
scripting with the offense and then we
you know wake up the next day and see
how he has responded he does you know
have his face mask ready to go when when
somebody says he is able but as far as
an exact date we don't we can say that
he's not playing game one and from that
point on it's sort of fluid what is the
biggest concern we're involving a face
under injury how do you handle yeah
I've probably be obvious you know
getting reheat in the face and you know
you see those athletes that play with a
mask you're always you know wondering
how does that affect somebody's well
obviously comfort level but vision line
you know like when you're shooting and
you're trying to pass to somebody I
think the obvious answer would be you
know are you going to get hit again in
that area
did you don't consult with him about
the actual mask that he was wearing
coach we almost in a humorous way like
you know there are so many designs
available to the athlete of what you
know you want sort of your personal mask
to look like and he sort of came up with
something Darth Vader is you know sort
of charcoal gray a deep sort of talked
charcoal gray and he you know it is a
process you get it fitted to your face
it's obviously something that ends up
being a significant part of trying not
to reinjure it but it did come with a
little bit of design thought Brett Brown
here on the Rich Eisen show Markel
thoughts how how much is he gonna get in
there do you think and the playoffs with
such a minimal amount of time as a as a
rookie under his belt I'm gonna try to
continue to play him like I have been
playing him I think to over think it at
the start we've won 16 games in a row
Wow we've played well at home since
Christmas especially and I feel like to
over think it would be a mistake you
know I had those great experience 12
years of them with pop and the Spurs and
you know the postseason deep into
postseason Championship stuff was a part
of my history in San Antonio and sort of
recall reflect back on some of those
preparation periods you know one of the
main things you get out of there is you
got to where you are for a reason and it
does change which when you start getting
into the series you know games 2 3 4 the
playoffs are so very different than the
regular season but initially I'm going
to play Markel like I have been playing
him which has been about you know 12 14
minutes 10 minutes as Ben Simmons back
up as a point guard so what are you
going to take from those Popovich years
now that you're you're going into your
your first foray with this team in the
playoffs what what are you what are you
looking at and calling from what
Popovich has been able to do in San
Antonio to tighten rotations defenses or
what have you coach you know I feel the
the the thing that most stands out is is
assessing like who you're going to
and trying to deliver a game plan to
your team that is very simple and clean
and you know go from a vanilla type base
and and start either you know tweaking
it a little bit or you know making some
subtle adjustments but I feel like if
you can select the proper game plan at
the start and you can walk it down that
that's the Holy Grail that's what we
always found our greatest success and so
the days after you know our last game
was against the Bucks yesterday we were
in spending so much time and we done a
lot of lead-up preparation with the
uncertainty of who we could have played
it could have been I think three or four
teams and we've ended up with Miami Heat
so a lot of groundwork had been done
previously but the past two days to
bring our team in and say listen these
are the matchups this is these are the
focal points offense defense and keep it
clean and deliver it with a sort of tone
of voice that is common confident and
let them practice it talk about it
that was our success a lot of times in
San Antonio have you openly talked about
winning it all with your with your guys
winning it all the whole thing no I mean
really think about our evolution we were
I mean I was advised at the start of the
year don't go there when I went to the
team from day one and said our goal is
to make the playoffs
you know like are we putting this team
too far ahead of it like you know we
really don't know what marquel is gonna
be or Ben or whatever and we I wanted to
own it like I really wanted to just put
it out there and own it with myself and
the players and you know our goal was to
make the playoffs and then life started
to move and then you you know you won
five games and eight games and you go
from seven to six and then you hang
there for a while then you you know beat
Cleveland and you're third and you've
broken an NBA record with 16 wins in a
row to conclude the regular season and
so you know our life is sped up but but
our goal and I think our futures what I
get most excited about I don't know what
this team is going to do in the playoffs
we've really never been Mia it's going
to be a journey note
but I see a big white light when I look
down the road at our future I really
feel good rich about you know Joelle's
health marquel's development we got
draft picks we have a salary cap space
we really have an amazing sort of
opportunity to grow something that I
think can sustain annual success the
coach why not now right I mean I don't
want to put any pressure or or put you
in a spot here but why not now I mean we
just saw a party trophy just salt with
Villanova right now that Philadelphia's
being called the city of Champions right
now in rich if if that's the way it
starts to point you are right and I go
into it sort of with a ready fire aim
mentality that you know sometimes you
know not knowing what you don't know
isn't a bad thing and you know the youth
that we have and playing free and we've
been playing so well and scoring the
ball and and you know play with a great
pace you don't know and it's you know
it's far for me to water anything down
they I hope will feed off my confidence
in them and uh we want to have some fun
you know I don't want to playoffs to
drown anybody's sort of ability to to be
proactive I want them plan free and I
want them playing confident do you have
any any any hoodies that you could put a
definition on it you champion right I
mean isn't that the the way to do it
these days based on what we saw with
Donovan Mitchell the other night yeah no
we haven't haven't gone me as we know no
no no no hoodies in Philly right now
with no definite so or process what
about that you could put process on a
hoodie explain what the new process is
which is city of Champions something
like yeah I'm going I flipped it I'm
going with trust the progress and I
think I I think yeah there you go
and so that's what I'm sticking with and
we're gonna we're gonna walk that that
mantra down for a while I like that and
then CIMMYT what do you say to those
like Donovan Mitchell that Ben Simmons
is not a rookie because he had a year
of sitting coach what's your position
you just think about that last word
sitting he didn't play he didn't play
and so you know you don't play or you do
and that's really my black-and-white
definition of a rookie and I think you'd
have to be reaching hard to to to truly
believe that Ben Simmons shouldn't be
Rookie of the Year I've said it here in
Philly I'll say it to you I think he is
the stone-cold Rookie of the Year I
don't really even think it's close and
I'll tell you what Donovan Mitchell has
been amazing he really has been amazing
he plays for a good friend of mine in
Quinn sighs Quinn Snyder and I just him
selfish here in Philly I look at our
record I look at what Ben has done and
you know he passed Earvin Magic Johnson
with with a triple-double accolade which
in many ways speaks for itself and very
excited that we gave him the ball you
know he's really I think proven a lot of
people wrong could he or couldn't he do
it and and I think to proof right now
says that yes he can well I mean the
winning streak that you mentioned of the
record to finish a regular season in the
NBA 16 six more wins than you had the
entire season a couple of years ago so
what what has been able to been cooked
up there by you and sticking to the
progress trusting the progress hashtag
it it's it's it's really something to
behold good luck to you in the
postseason coach yeah rich good stuff
thanks for having me you bet always
that's Brett Brown 76ers head coach so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience